mystery je suis navré j'ai très peu de
temps allant droit au but
hier une bande de rebelles à pirater
votre réseau yara vision
non ne tirez pas il réclamait qu'on
libère de prétendus faria de caen qui
produisent du viraux ce sont des
esclaves qui font ce poignet le veer on
sauve des vies pensez vous que la
provenance porte à ses patients vous
avez été emprisonné à l'âge de 13 ans
l'âge actuel de diego vous passer du
temps avec votre père c'est un bon
enseignant le lion c'est se calmer
avant de frapper
je crois savoir qu à 15 ans vous a forcé
à travailler dans un champs de tabac et
vous auriez encore la lame
quand yara sera un paradis
mes méthodes
seront ignorés
de la seule survivante j'ai vu castillo
faire exécuter un bateau rempli des
nôtres
tirez vous aussi loin que possible de ce
psychopathe tirez vous la révolution
n'est pas gagné parce qu'ils ne
craignent rien mais parce qu'ils sont
creux
bienvenue chez libertad d'année
j'ai comme projet de reconstruire le
paradis achmed le viron le traitement
anticancer le plus efficace du monde
entier cultivé dans nos champs de tabac
mais notre paradis a un prix ça nous et
demi ne le comprendront jamais sorte à
les consulter
tu veux que tu anton quartier tué un
dictateur qui a volé nos terres et qui a
fait de nous des esclaves
ça sans visage où es tu en penses quoi
tu vas devenir une légende pour les
guérilleros
je ne suis pas sans crainte mais je vous
promets une chose
je sais
il ya les lions
desagneaux
wei
soum et oies les à lyon égaux et nous
nous dévorons laisse à nyon
[Musique]
à découvrir sur la toute nouvelle xbox